It's gonna be the best vacation ever
Seriously you have to try
I don't even know how to dive
It's totally save
Okay
It's like you're going to the zoo except you're in the cage
I don't know about this
welcome aboard
There! Look
It's huge
Remember, the faster you breathe the faster you use up your air.
Trust me. Once you're down there, you're not gonna want to come back up
This is amazing
It kinda takes your breath away
Oh my god
It's the biggest shark!
Will you take a picture of me?
Sorry, sorry!
We would like to come back up now
We're bringing you back up
oh my god
I'm so scared
We need to get you some air
How deep are we?
47 meters
Hello is anyone there?
Please someone answer me!
We need to get back up to the top
Can you hear me?
We're gonna send down extra air tanks
I'm so lost
Stay in the cage
We have no air
We have to go now
There are sharks everywhere!
47 Meters Down